like lost pieces of a scattered jigsaw
puzzle finally returns to their origin
here the head of a boy but also part of
a horse's head and the head of a bearded
man
three fragments of one of the wonders of
ancient Athens a sculpted marble freeze
that once wrapped the Parthenon Temple
now they're back in Greece presented by
a representative of Pope Francis the
gifting of the fragments of the pratinum
which have been held in the Vatican
Museums for more than two centuries
shows itself as an iglesio cultural and
social gesture of friendship and
solidarity with the people of Greece
the Greek government is hoping gestures
like this add to the growing momentum
for the return of other Parthenon
sculptures from International
collections
the ceremony today which completes the
exceptionally generous gesture by Pope
Francis similar to the gesture from the
government of Sicily and the Republic of
Italy a few months ago shows the road
that we could follow that everyone could
follow in order for the unity of the
Parthenon to be restored
there is no bigger collection of
Parthenon marbles than that held by the
British museum about half the existing
sculptures are in London where they've
been since British nobleman Lord Elgin
was allowed to take them from Athens by
Greece's ottoman rulers in the early
1800s
the British museum says it will happily
loan them to Greece but Greece which
considers Britain's ownership of the
marbles illegal won't ask to borrow
items it believes are rightfully Greek
and so the argument has gone for decades
now recent secret talks between the
British Museum and the Greek government
were rumored to be making progress on a
complex deal but a 1963 law forbids the
Museum from giving away artifacts in its
collection and prime minister Rishi
sunak says there are no plans to change
this so while some Western collections
are reconsidering their ownership of
Acquisitions made during the Age of
Empires for now the British museum is
not one of them Rory challenge Al
Jazeera London